so we have the same set up here as we
had in the previous problem in problem
number 42 where p is an odd prime number
and they say let t sub p be the
following set of two by two matrices
where each of those matrices have the
form a's along the diagonals and then a
b there and a c there and each of those
numbers are between 0 and p minus 1
inclusive so they can be 0 1 2 3 all the
way up to p minus 1.
and then the number 43 they ask us the
number of a
in the set such that the trace of a the
trace of a is not divisible by p but the
determinant of a is divisible by p
but the determinant of a is divisible by
p is and then they tell us the trace of
a matrix is the sum of its diagonal
entries it's actually the sum of its
main diagonal it's not going to be that
diagonal it's only the sum of this if
you sum this you're going to get the
trace of the matrix so let's use let's
use this first piece of information the
trace of a is not divisible by p so the
trace of a is going to be a plus a or 2a
so 2a not
not divisible
not divisible
by
not divisible by p
so that means so let's think of a
situation where 2a is divisible by p
so if 2a
so 2a could be equal to 0 because 0 is a
multiple of p in which case a would be
equal to zero so this is a possibility
so if a is equal to zero then two a is
divisible by p so this tells us
so this one of the constraints from this
sentence right here is that a cannot be
equal to zero because if a is zero then
the trace is divisible by b so a cannot
be equal to 0. and let's think about it
can 2a become any other multiple of b
can 2a
can 2a equal p
well if 2a equaled p then 2 and a would
be factors of b and then p would not be
prime and so we can cross that out and
then 2a
can't be equal to 2p that would make a
equal to p which is impossible because a
can only be p minus 1. so that's not
possible and then you can keep going
higher higher multiples of p not
possible
because a is going to be smaller than b
so the only constraint that we get from
this first sentence the trace of a is
not divisible by b tells us that a
does not equal zero so now let's look at
the second constraint the determinant of
a is divisible
but the determinant of a is divisible by
p so the determinant of a let me write
this the determinant of a
is equal to a times a it's equal to a
squared minus
b times c or c times b so minus bc so
this is going to be divisible so this is
going to be divisible by p this is going
to be equal to some integer times
times p
now one thing
just looking at this there's no obvious
simplification here but one thing i'm
starting to appreciate not having taken
the iit joint entrance exam when i was
in high school not growing up in india
is that when they have multiple choices
sometimes it might be faster to just do
the brute force method when i say the
brute force method not just proving
mathematically which of these
expressions are true but just let's try
a simple p
let's try a simple p and then let's find
the number of the the members of the set
that would satisfy it for that p and
then see which of these expressions
equal that p let's see what we get so
let's just simplify this let's just say
p is equal to 3
and i pick p is equal to 3 because
that's the smallest odd prime number
it's the smallest number that satisfies
this constraint up here so let's set p
is equal to three so if p is equal to
three our possibilities for a
are possibilities for a are that a could
be equal to a can't be equal to zero we
know that already a cannot be equal to
zero so a could be equal to one or a
could be equal
or a could be equal to two
and if a is equal to one then the
determinant of a
the determinant of a is going to be
equal to 1 minus bc
1 minus bc which needs to be equal to
which needs to be equal to some integer
multiple of 3
because we said our p is equal to three
must be equal to three k
if a is equal to two then the
determinant is going to be four because
it's a squared a squared so it's going
to be four minus bc
must be equal to some integer multiple
of three so let's see how many
combinations of b and c we can find in
each of these constraints
so one minus bc so one possibility
one possibly let's think about it so one
possibility is one minus bc is equal to
three times zero that's one possibility
maybe another possibility is one minus
bc
is equal to
is equal to
three
is equal to actually let's think about
this a little bit let me try this
possibility here first so if one minus
bc is equal to zero this is pretty
straightforward bc would have to be
equal to one and so b and c would have b
would have to be equal to one and c
would have to be equal to one so we have
one combination here a could be equal to
one a could be equal to one b is equal
to one and c is equal to one
that is one possibility right over there
and then another possibly now
no matter what bc we pick here
the maximum we could the maximum value
here is going to be one if bc are both
zero then this expression is going to be
one if they're both one this expression
is going to be zero if they're any other
value and the only other values that
they could be are some combination of 1
and 2 or 2 and 2
then we're going to get a negative
number so the question is
is a negative multiple of 3 considered
to be a multiple of 3 and let's just
figure it out assuming it is and then we
could see which of maybe if one of these
expressions makes sense and i'm going to
do that in in white just because depends
if you consider negative 3 divisible by
3 then we should go with that so maybe
we should say 1 minus bc
could be equal to
negative 3 could be equal to negative 3
which is the same thing as bc minus 1 is
equal to 3 which is the same i just
multiplied both sides by negative 1
which is the same thing as bc is equal
to 4
and we have to be careful here you might
be tempted to say b is equal to 1 c is
equal to 4 or b is equal to 4 c is equal
to 1 but they can't be equal to 4. 4 is
bigger than our p they can only be up to
2. so this constraint is only b is equal
to 2
and c is equal to 2 and of course a is
equal to one so this is if you do
consider negative three to be divisible
by three which it actually is it is it's
negative one times three it is a
multiple so this would be one of the
cases but i'll put that there just in
case you never know what the test
writers were actually thinking so i'll
put there there as kind of a contingent
case
and then this last situation 4 minus bc
is equal to 3k so 4 minus bc
could be equal to
could be equal to
0
or 4 minus bc let's think about it 4
minus bc could be equal to 0 it could 4
minus bc
could be equal to 3 that's definitely a
possibility because this value right
here will always be less than 4
and you can't get anything less than 0
here because the highest value for b and
c are both 2 2 times 2 is going to be 4
so you can't get anything less than 0
here so you won't have a case like this
so i just said it so if you have this
equation that means 4 is equal to bc the
only possibility with b and c being less
than 3 being 0 1 or 2 is that b is equal
to 2
and c is equal to 2. neither of one of
those could be equal to 4 because that's
bigger than our p and so here we have a
is equal to 2
a is equal to 2 b is equal to 2 and c is
equal to 2.
and then if 4 minus bc is equal to 3
that means that this that bc has to be
equal to 1
bc is equal to one and so the only
possibility is that let me scroll to the
right b is equal to one and c is equal
to one and of course a is equal to two
and a is equal to two
so we've been able to list four distinct
possibilities four distinct matrices for
our p is equal to three now let's see if
any of these evaluate to four
when p is equal to three
let me put this down here so if we have
three minus two sorry three minus one
that's two three squared nine minus
three is six plus one is seven so this
is two times seven that's fourteen that
doesn't evaluate to four
this is 27 minus 4
20 this is 23 also doesn't evaluate to 4
3 minus 1 squared that's 2 squared this
evaluates to 4. so this is looking
pretty good we just have to hope that
something else doesn't evaluate to 4.
this is 2 3 minus 1 is 2 times
7. once again this is also 14 not there
so i would go with c and so the exam
writers really did want negative 3 to be
a possible or they really do view
negative three as being divisible by
three which it is which it is so but you
know sometimes people think of it only
as kind of positive multiples but it
clearly is divisible by three so our
answer is c